今日はず社長です皆さん今までユーチューバーとか僕もフク子なんですけどさまざまな
人がこんなんか宙に浮きたいというかマールでさあ突っ張り棒とかそうだってこ何か
部屋で一定の固定で一定の魂がでこう維持したいっていう気持ちがユーチューバーには
なぜかとても多いという傾向が見られるような気がしておりますほとんど僕の実験は
失敗すっぱり講師は無理って事も僕は勝って
いましたしガムテープで10%増につこうとしているようななんかや方もいました
様々なユーチューバーがたくさんいる中で私も確実に今回の方が絵も本当に安牌をとっ
てほぼ確実に古典上でくっついては貼りください筋トレとかもしてしまおうかなと思っ
ておりまぁ今回こちら心経試作勝負レース調で見覚えないでしょうか日本語で言うと
逆だったいわゆるバックゲームカップというねこれどんなときに使うかと言いますと車
とかがぶつかったりしてところの時に野球部で航空機を吸って取れなくなっていっぱり
と冬場の結構3が奪ってなおるって言うそれでちょっと強力な代物です
上屋れがちも長いもうあこれですよこれ
これが40バキュームかどうやって使うんだろちゃんとついてみせよ
ハンドルなるどこにもないよこういうところにくっつけるのかなもう食べて車に付け
るって事はこういう事にぶつけるとか見たわけですよ
よくわかんねえ応答とよ dqn 女カップの付け方がわからないし説明書が英語飲ん
では打ってから今日は家の中で
あやばいってばまた一般店
あればとりあえず出ちゃった妻からぞやばいれていただいた
そういうことで大古でございますぜひが出来ますこれフォーハンド予算前にこれパパっ
て付けた後にとれたてにこのハンドルをくいっていると空気が抜けるみたいですねっ
もんだよねーこれ言ったこれじゃないどっます
マジか
例えば完全パスってくるちょっとてんじゃ微妙など他のボス行ってみましょう
あっやばいじゃあ絶対建造落ちてくるからそれでいい役は下げていかないのでなんで
コーヒー場所じゃないかと思ったんですけども
扉なく作れるんじゃないかと思います
ああいいねん
いいよいいんじゃなくなってやら完璧ですみたい
完璧にももう絶対取れないからまず読めない写メ受けずに
いやいやまたか
はいというわけで家の色などを探したんですけども私は気付いてしまった俺の家で切り
ますはない
転造勉強にポツポツしてるんでバンキングから5天井にくっつけは37
横にあってもうずれるんだよねちゃんとやっぱ上につけてコースないとたぶんちょっと
z 乙って好きさんから失敗することは僕も分かったのでエラーでなんとかして綴るの
天井付
目指しますそこで使うのがコツらー
もうここしかないしその相座を左手この間にあっ
テーブルをかけて付けて俺はつの亀裂
パーク集この間に救いを挟みます
もう行けないん
は具合がバラと見落とされますよ
のズっていい
ワッハじゃあそんな思いですぐ持ってみたことないちょっと距離縮めたのでこれでおい
てみます
日本へ来たーーおっと祝いたかったんです
一体さあ母親にぜひこの時できたいろんなユーチューバーを繰り返して挑んできた
室内でウコンロス初めてじゃないだろうか
エイ
ていくぜ
います3
ブーブそう
います
voodoo
なって買ってアホ